look it really is stunning how this
pendulum has swung for the titans in a
week last week the league was telling
other teams that the titans were facing
a historic punishment the league was
telling them that league employees were
saying we have to get them for this we
have no choice they didn't follow the
protocols they had this this practice
session or more than one practice
session there were rumors a coach was at
the practice sessions
they were getting ready yeah to hit the
titans like no team has ever been hit
before
and then something happened they backed
off yesterday there was a conference
call the commissioner talking about the
situation in tennessee our focus isn't
punishment it's safety and then
right at the outset of the broadcast
last night on cbs national platform jay
feely said the commissioner told him no
one from tennessee willingly violated
the protocols there it is there there it
is who they're not going to punish
anybody for accidentally violating the
protocols when everyone's accidentally
violating the protocols so you know this
weird balance the nfl is trying to
strike between deterrence but also not
making it so big of an issue that it
overwhelms the football season they want
to talk about football and focus on
football
well
if you have somebody that you think is
violating the rules
and uh the only way to handle it is to
punish them but you want the focus to be
on football that's when you have to walk
away and i think at the end of the day
the nfl realized you know what we may be
stepping into a problem here because
look at what happened with deflategate
the fight that we bought ourselves with
the patriots right look what happened
with the bounty scandal the fight that
we bought ourselves with the saints
those all played out in the off season
the last thing the nfl needed is to get
itself into a fight whether in
arbitration litigation public relations
however
a fight with the titans that would have
caused the titans to say look at what
everyone else is doing you're factually
wrong you're trumping up the charges you
know we've seen that before with both
the saints case and the patriots case
where facts were trumped up frankly
the nfl wisely deciding
now isn't the time to take on that kind
of a fight not when we're trying to hold
together with duct tape and glue a
football season that is careening toward
an 18th week maybe a 19th week right and
maybe canceled games well i i guess i
understand it from the nfl standpoint i
do i mean
maybe they deal with it in the off
season if they have to i i don't know
you know where they go from there mike i
had kind of heard the same thing from
somebody i trust involved with the
league last week too
that you know the titans that there was
talk that they could be in big trouble
that they might come down with a heavy
hand maybe that was being said just to
scare them and other teams i don't know
maybe that was the nfl's plan just to
kind of oh everybody's ears are perked
up right now because of what's going on
in tennessee let's kind of tell
everybody that they might face bad
discipline to get everybody back on
their p's and q's maybe maybe that
there's a problem though here's the
problem though yeah if you huff and puff
and don't blow the house down what
message does that ultimately send to the
other team you're right right i guess
unless yeah
unless there's a memo that's sent out at
some point saying
hey we've been through this for three
months now and we're all learning on the
fly but now we all know what the rules
are and we're telling you going forward
if anybody fails to comply you're done
yeah that that's the only way to to
breathe any relevance into them because
they weren't they were sending the
message last week the titans are going
to get it the titans are going to get it
and now they're not going to get it and
the other teams are looking at saying
well i guess there is no consequence if
you violate these protocols well yeah i
and i hope the teams aren't looking at
it that way i hope the teams are looking
at it more like whoa tennessee still
almost screwed up the season for a lot
of people here let's not be that team i
hope you know but you're right i mean
that's going to fall onto some deaf ears
a little bit when they see there's no
repercussions or anything like that but
i i'm i'm guessing that i i'm i'm with
you i think the nfl just looked at it
and went we're going about to get into a
fight that's going to distract
and cause other issues here other than
just like we're just happy we're playing
football let's kind of keep the
attention on that for right now and not
make more of a divide with the fans or
anything like that about is it safe or
whatever else and i think they probably
fell back into the human aspect of the
conversation to like what mike vrabel
said from the get-go which there is
definitely you have like it's nobody's
fault you know yeah there it's it's this
is a pandemic
so as much as we've heard and we think
why it got in their building and things
like that you know i don't know it
doesn't seem like we know that concrete
answer and of course there's a lot of
variables right now with the way the nfl
is handling this situation to where guys
could get the the virus and uh so i get
why the nfl did it mike i think you're
right i think that's probably the reason
why they did it
i don't want to get too far inside
baseball here but the titans have now
stared down the nfl a couple of times
there's been an ownership
structure issue since the passing of bud
adams with how he's bequeathed the team
and where control of the team is and the
nfl was pushing and pushing and pushing
and the titans pushed back and the nfl
backed off so the titans are winning on
the field and the titans are winning off
the field hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports